vediamoli non litigare perché come
sapete tutti eh non sono per niente
competitivo come fa la gente si scivoli
va più veloce Non lo sapevo ma da quando
folgais ma insegna maleste tattiche io
non lo sapevo Togliti Ma perché esisti
nella tua vita schifosa Allora
maledizione no no no no no ci può
saltare da una parte all'altra No
secondo me perché sennò sarebbe troppo
facile quando sono scarso Toglietemi
Madonna ragazzi ma quanto è difficile
questa partita vi dovete togliere sono
il maestro dello scivolo e ho passato la
vita a giocare ai videogiochi se non
vinco qua mi sento veramente uno sfigato
cronico Ok attenzione
[Applauso]
per niente ansiogeno questo gioco zero